the storms comin on your faces wash off
Captain Boomerang Suicide Squad digger
Harkness Ozzy larrikin I can't wait to
do it again
Carl Reese I mean Terminator Genisys
that was huge I don't know working with
Arnie and Emilia Clarke have amazing
time don't think I'll get to do it again
borrow ya borrow got killed at the end
of season one finally enough one of the
roles that I think I get recognized most
for still you know which is kind of
crazy because that thing has such reach
that was my introduction to this world
of on-screen performance really and a
very special project close to my heart
gah gah gah that was a lot of fun that
was totally out of left field but
getting to to play opposite Amy Poehler
and you know that whole gang I just that
was like a total right I hadn't I didn't
know anything about that heading in I
didn't I wasn't raised on the original
film so I had all this kind of no
context and I remember like watching the
series that they've done which was a
pretty cool or a sequel or something and
kind of been like but this is totally
bonkers but that was a real joy to get
to play yeah Eric a couple holes in the
head there don't miss having to scrub
the transfer tattoos off my freshly
shaven neck every day yeah let's leave
that one in the past
hideaway tom reclusive fractured
individual but a loving father and and a
really special role for me to play a
real change of pace getting to to father
a child on screen and they have such an
intimate relationship with my son played
by Finn little in stone boy of course
yeah yeah
total privilege he's a good boy you're
lucky man
April 5th select theaters check out the
storms
[Music]